you and your beautiful wife Penelope
Cruz us both have Oscars that is
uncommon for a couple to have where do
you guys keep your Oscar 30 do I say the
truth yes in the night table
these are night lamps we have put some
light ball yeah we switch them on and we
read with them and we read a lot of
books because that's the only way for us
to remind us how good we are because
because the Oscars are they're always on
and then we read we receive our people
or guests at home like Jack Horner and
John Lennon yeah on the bed reading
books so they can see the Oscar wait
that's the truth wait you're saying that
if Andy and I were to visit you know
Penelope you would invite us into your
bed and we happy with you yes with the
Oscar lamps on either side yeah and they
will we will all read books together you
start reading the book and then you fall
asleep you know I did speak at the
Oscars I saw you on the Oscars we all
saw you you were part of the telecast
they cut to you while Queen was
performing yes and you were rocking out
it was in let's take a look this is very
impressive
[Music]
I was very surprised about that that
opening and you didn't know that was
gonna happen I had the chance to have
Queen right in front of me and it was
amazed by that
so you just that was spontaneous yeah
and started well but I don't have the
heart to bump my head but yeah I tried
that's why the horn the horn oh yeah
yeah but I broke this finger many years
ago so this doesn't work your horn is
all messed up yeah that's great though
[Laughter]
[Applause]